i don't think any of us sleep
particularly well when we've been on an
evening
and you can never ever be totally
prepared on community there's always
something that you just think oh my
goodness what what do we do
lisa bingham is one of around 10 000
district nurses in britain
she treats the sick in their own homes
and during the pandemic she's often been
the only link her patients have had with
the outside world
since coving the calls have just been
coming thick and fast
as a nurse you want to help people don't
you and if you've got calls coming in
saying somebody's in pain they can't go
to the toilets past you're in there in
agony and you've got nobody to send you
know you you just feel guilty
this is the district nurse's holy boot
got a bit of everything in our boot bp
machines blood sugars you just need to
prepare to go to
anything or everything
have they turned it today sweetheart
this morning she did it this morning
okay no worries
jeff is 77
he is facing up to the fight of his life
right now battling tongue cancer but
there's one person who's always been by
his
side we've been trained for a very long
time well for some 77 years now sir we
really were identical twins
you wouldn't have known the difference
between us
which is at the moment is hard to
believe but uh
people say is there a special sort of
relationship between brothers and twins
and
the answer is probably yes the problem
is
because as twins you're automatically
thrown together
are you putting through in everything
okay
you can't state
how important it is
it's
we would be lost without this
we wouldn't have a chance we we wouldn't
know what to do
they are more important to me than we
are still at the moment
i feel
a lot better because of them
then
i would probably now just be saying oh i
ain't bothering you
and i wouldn't do the job myself
i i'd probably give up on it
i'll see you again now i've met you now
i know where you are don't i so you
won't be able to position me oh well
this is true
the pandemic has tested this service to
the limits
and it's not over
we're literally out on our own and we
have to make the decisions
we've got out of hours gps but at the
moment it's been an hour and a half on
the phone and we just can't get through
and and then
you are
literally just trying to come up with a
solution to help that patient the best
you can at the time
[Music]
two long years of a pandemic have taken
their toll on the national health
service
it is right now going through the most
difficult winter in its history
we're in a little bit of a surreal
position we've had a really difficult
few weeks as everyone's aware
our diagnostics on the call no we're
struggling with uh stopping okay so ed
we've got weights in ed of just over 20
hours at the moment i've got um no beds
at the moment
embedded area in esh1 is full with no
discharges planned we are looking at
cancellation of routine cases i think we
all know what we need to do so if we
meet back at 12 o'clock with an update
thank you very much
how difficult has it been in the last
few weeks to run a hospital
difficult question
it's been incredibly incredibly
challenging and actually my resilience
has been tested in terms of
coming into work every day
take your time
and help you know this
but actually people look on you as a
role model
in terms of
um that leadership and assistance
so you have to keep going
and that's really tough
so i know you're waiting for a bed on
the ward aren't you edna are you waiting
you're waiting to go to the ward
so you've got two patients yeah my
name's tracy i'm one of the senior
sisters of the emergency department
we are the front door so you never know
what's coming through that door we see
all types of people from minor injuries
simple fracture right up to people that
come in in cardiac arrest having heart
attacks
how i can describe is you'll walk into
your shift and you you're in your
uniform you walk into your shift and
that's it nurse head goes on
[Applause]
because you know then that you are busy
and you know that you have got to stay
focused positive and get through that
shift and some days you can go in and
you've got 50 plus patients in your
department at seven o'clock in the
morning
28 year old craig powell is seriously
ill part of his bowel has ruptured and
he needs urgent surgery
but he's already been waiting here for
10 hours and there are no operating
theaters available we haven't got a bed
for him currently and he does need to be
operated on fairly urgently right so
craig powell can you tell me is he
covered negative is he testing green so
what we'll do is we'll do a little bit
of moving around any movement any plan
movement
surgical bed manager liz brooks has no
choice but to cancel a less urgent
operation so that craig can be helped
so that's what a patient sadly died on
there just now so
but amid the bustle
kovid continues to cast its shadow
so we really are getting to the point
where critical care capacity is
absolutely
limited yep
okay so i want to see if i can do some
sort of deal currently i haven't got to
bed but it's really going to be
happening quite soon
there is a simple truth in the nhs the
most seriously ill are seen first and
that means others have to make way hello
is it craig my name's liz i'm the
surgical event manager
are you heading off to theater now oh
you're going to theater that's fine
that's lovely so um we'll be sorting
that bed out for you so no worries
sometimes urgency takes precedence so
obviously if someone is very very sick
in ed they are going to get a little bit
more precedence over someone who's been
planned for a routine operation
and so almost 6 million patients are now
waiting for planned treatment on the nhs
and that number is expected to rise to
12 million by this time next year
[Applause]
i was blue lighted here and today is my
36th day in hospital
so i wanted to come
down and then drive back up and while
millions wait to get into hospital
many thousands are desperate to get out
doing really well here
paul's a diabetic
his infected foot became so bad there
was only one
option when
they told me i was going to lose me uh
below the knee
i've had better days
good not every amputee gets to the point
where they're standing up
i mean mom died uh on the 23rd of
december
and uh my sister's put everything back
to try and get me home
for the 10th of february when my mom's
funerals so
they're saying they want me to put it in
a nurse you know and i said i've
flatly refused
i just want to go home i need to grieve
and i can do that with my family
yeah
well done mate so the first time you
stood isn't it yeah everything's
pointing the right direction good job
matt
thank you cheers
paul can't be discharged without a plan
for his care and so his local social
services department must now arrange
help at home but that service is under
pressure too
and so for now he's stuck on this ward
paul's at a point now where being in
hospital doesn't benefit him he needs to
be in his own environment so he
continues longer term rehab
[Applause]
there are still many patients here with
covid19
but there are signs of recovery for
those most seriously ill
ian has been on intensive care for seven
weeks
struck down with kovid
i was the last one to speak to him and
say
you know
all sorted out
and you call
[Applause]
ian was double vaccinated but caught
covered a week before he was due to have
his booster
the first time i come to see him was
christmas day
and that was that was the first day he
opened his eyes it was just like he'd
been give the world
especially a big christmas day
it was like
it's like a miracle really
yeah
the intensive care ward is much quieter
than it used to be most here are
unvaccinated they line their beds
helpless relying on medicine to make it
out alive
i'm lisa by the way nice to meet you
oh bless him
ken is 75 lives with his wife jenny
she's got cancer of pancreas
right if i can just look at your notes
then and i can see what i can give you
if that's okay
ken had surgery and was for a time in
remission
but a few months ago the pain returned
and ken was sent for a scan
and that scan showed that the cancer had
come back
it has spread to my
liver
and basically there was there was
nothing more that they could do
the services we've got from palliative
care and the district nurses
are the supports there they're on the
end of the phone
he just feels like rubbish
at the moment
so the future is
likely to be short
which is hard
how are you
tired
it's just everything
that i'm going to be leaving behind
jenny
the life of the known
the things i do the games i play
all the things i like to do i can't do
them anymore
and
knowing it's you know it's coming to the
end of everything
i've just got to accept that that's the
case
and get on with it
but there you go sometimes it gets you
they've told you that your core if
needed
then the day team start again it's
actually the first time i'd met ken and
jenny but he obviously wanted to
to share a lot more so you need to be
there and you you can't just stop in the
middle of a conversation like that and
say i'm really sorry we'll talk next
time you've got to be there and listen
because he might not
have that opportunity again
[Music]
the pandemic has placed enormous
pressures throughout the nhs
what happens in one part of this complex
service has inevitable consequences
elsewhere
it is a daily struggle for staff and
their patients
nick martin sky news